when you hear certain songs do you go
yeah that takes me back to a really bad
time like are there certain two songs
that you don't even like to think about
because they're probably like snapshots
for you they're probably like well yeah
i remember what i was doing back then
and i just there is one there is one and
i won't ever play it again because um
there's a song on
uh the who are you album it's called the
music must change and every time we
played that in the studio keith couldn't
play the drums to it it was in a kind of
three-four
and he just keith couldn't play normal
drums
keith could play great moon drums and
that was it he couldn't get that
particular thing he just couldn't do
that you know uh so he so we had to do
it with a pair of squeaky boots walk in
the pavement he's kind of squeaking walk
doing the rhythm
and anyway so keith is not on that
recording on the record
and
wow straight after we made that record
he died oh right so the memory is hey
keith had a bad experience with that and
then he died and it's kind of
unfortunate that he died and probably
his confidence was shook because he
couldn't play that song that's part of
it part of it yeah is that what's
negative for you about it
well it goes on um we didn't play we
played the song on
when we got back together with kenny
jones's drummer and we played that for a
little while on stage and then we
dropped it for a long long long time we
bought it back in 2002
when we toured the last tour with john
epperson
and we rehearsed it and we were going to
do it in the show and john died
[Laughter]
so it's become unlucky that song well i
kind of got a weird feeling about it
because it is about
how it's got to move on you know and
that is our time to move on really yeah
and we were all getting in the way